ich bin absolut beeindruckt
jetzt kann ich sagte ja dokumentarfilm
gemacht und sie im leben street als
viertes vollständig standen also sich
unglaublich spiel
ich freue mich mit euch schaffe und es
gibt glaube ich accuity zieht die
regisseur von die schweizermacher rolf
lyssy dreht wieder ein spielfilm
statt ihm alters turnen verbringt der 80
jährige seine zeit lieber auf dem
filmset
ich weiß gar nicht was ruhe stand ist
petra fuhrmann
[Musik]
in lyss neuem spielfilm die letzte
potter geht es um eine alte frau die
angst hat dement zu werden
verpackt in eine komödie warum fehlt
rolf ließ sie trotz seiner 80 jahre
immer noch weiter und wie schafft er es
der schwere im leben etwas leichtes
abzugewinnen
davon handelt dieser film
[Musik]
ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja und dann ließ
sparringpartner sein sohn ali ali ali
sie ist kameramann und lebt in new york
es ist nicht das erste mal dass sie
zusammenarbeiten das ist wenn es krank
wenn ich mir immer gewünscht und geht
dann ja vorher schon mit dem raum
geschafft aber geschätzte spielfilm im
spiel fehlen die letzte ponte geht es um
demenz und sterbehilfe
wolf ließ sie haben immer
gesellschaftlich relevante themen
interessiert keine seichte komödien
dort wo sich humor und tragik kreuzten
werde es spannend problem hat sie als
vergesse und du hast das problem und
durch weitere also blieb sie freundlich
bis jetzt auf dem gesicht ich eigentlich
nur das lachen
berlin hat das jüngste alltag seit ich
verliere mich in rimini schauspielerin
das buch ich verdammt oder und ich würde
das eigentlich unterschrieben
man muss man muss können bedarf kranke
von arche oder wenn man vor der
mannschaft wenn man die stanz bucht dann
dampf unglaublich funktioniert nicht
die letzte platte ist eine schweizer
großproduktion mit einer filmcrew von 40
leuten
das gewicht und die sparte funktioniert
elia ließ sie hat die new york film
studiert und sich als kameramann
ausbilden lassen dass auch er ins
filmbusiness möchte war ihm schon früh
klar die jungwähler helmand unterwegs
und mini er stehe für die waadt ist
einfach keine küsse schauspieler kommen
und die verschiedene der gruppe vor dem
mikro lozano gestern morgen küssel gehen
und dann schafft man ganztag und es ist
es rein und machen des wagens baustellen
und des danke sagen und super und dann
ist mit meter großes loch
durch ihre wahl die welt von den erhöht
doch die filmwelt kann ungerecht sein
die voerder gremien stur niemand weiß
das besser als höflich sie obwohl er
einer der erfolgreichsten schweizer
filmemacher ist wurden seine projekte
immer wieder abgelehnt
ich bin fokussiert mini arbeit die viele
fehler machen und viel machen in der
schweiz ist also das ist chaotisch
das ist hardcore und zwar auf jeder
ebene und die augen bereich kritisiert
man wird krank man wird verletzt man
wird erlaubt hamilton freut alters in
der bilanz kann ich mich eigentlich
nicht beschweren erfolge gewinn gemacht
und nur eine mehrere also könnte ich
also glück ist alles gut gegangen aber
dass kunden vorher meine leidenschaft
ich bin viel machen
mit acht jahren ist rolf ließ sie mit
der familie von der stadt zürich nach
heribert gezogen
damals in den 40er jahren ein
verschlafenes bauerndorf der stadt junge
fühlt es sich wie von einem anderen
planeten
der unterschiedliche eklatant pedro und
auch natürlich aus einer völlig anderen
kultur nicht nur status und
jüdische kultur in santo die anderen das
sind es die pure bourbon und ich kann
mich auch sofort abgesetzt und den
anderen habe ich akzeptiert oder ich
auch risiko aber immer so schön sei auch
exotisch aber es sind dunkle was alles
mit aus ca sie sind der einzige jüdische
burgdorf sie ist das ist thema der hand
sie das gemerkt
naja du ich bin seltener gast sie
überreichte führen die rotjacken keine
glückliche ja zwischendurch wollen
inzwischen getrennt hat
da bin ich 40 15 das ist aber nicht
weniger schmerzhaft sie also ich hatte
gastraum eingefangen oder aber ich habe
ständig das muss ich sagen so frau kino
fasziniert hat doch wo
olaf durchschaut hat und als puppen oder
und und geschichte erzählt er
geschichten aus ihrem leben 14
das bindet oder dass ich bin mein vater
mit erfolg sie wie löst man sich dann
irgendwann versonnen stache mutter der
1000 schied aber ganz so gut ist kann
sich überhaupt lösen je pfund schwere
auseinandersetzung gekommen in meinem
ort und dann im winter werde somit mit
christian in einem brief geschrieben und
langendreer und das ist so eine art
bilanz xing oder kritische sehr
kritische in zusammenhang mit dem vater
ordentlich armin veh vor ihm immer
wieder wasser unter dem einfluss von
meiner mutter
also das sind prägen die romantik und
irgendwann muss man eine wende
rolf ließ eltern stammen beide aus
frommern jüdischen hause
doch besonders seine mutter war dem
judentum gegenüber kritisch eingestellt
er wurde zwar nicht religiöser zogen
trotzdem pflegte man jüdische
traditionen verpflichtet mich inneren
auto schnell wo das glaubt was seht und
hört
und ich hasse mission ihre vertrags
überhaupt immer da wo mission ist spiel
kommt und das ist mit regionen eine
jesus geburt oder man muss an der
menschen über züge von dem was man
selber denkt oder glaubt da bin ich also
ein paar dörfer weiter als herrliberg in
männedorf hat rolf ließ ist eine
ausbildung gemacht
foto lehre gemacht drüben louis kurs
startet noch fotokunst ich dass der
anfang eigentlich vor ihre filmkarriere
xxi außerdem fehlen beschleunigt und
holt das ist nicht möglich sie und kann
man wir können leere film schon als kaka
und dann der neue indische foto foto
graf foto jetzt macht man doch wollte er
unbedingt irgendwie in die filmszene
reinkommen was sind dann später auch
gelang
er arbeitete als aufnahmeleiter
beleuchter und kameraassistent rolf ließ
sie und das kino wilden mann in
männedorf verbindet eine lange
geschichte
er setzte sich dafür ein dass das studio
kino nach einem brand wieder aufgebaut
wurde
hier beim letzten film festival war wolf
ließ sie der ehrengast an dem auto die
20 jahre ist es im schaukelstuhl
filmprojekte und das ist dort darüber
großes engagement für den film für
dieses projekt er hat mit dem echten ist
einer von sieben neuen film erzählt und
der funke übergesprungen
und dazu kommt dass sie fähig sind
der schweizer macht ist 40 jahre alt der
hamburger um befindet begriffe bis
zwischendrin die schweizermacher
begeisterte ein millionenpublikum
dieser film klebe wie einmal auf seiner
stirn erzählt rolf lyssy damit habe er
sich inzwischen abgefunden
der erfolg vor schweizermacher hat
überrascht also idee muss maus oder das
audiobuch der geschichte ist dass man
einen film macht und wo man mit größeren
allure und zeige aber dass das dann so
ich lauter
die kleinstadt träumen was hat sie für
reaktionär für ihren film freunde auf
der willen also früh ernst freud und
viele angriffe druckte und dann gefunden
ich weiß nur in solothurn die
solothurner filmtage hat das tv kino so
erfolgreich oder komödie dass ich damals
ist viel geht wo also ich hatte nie der
fall missgunst der fahrer und das st
rolf ließ sie war immer schon ein
grübler ein zweifel
nach der trennung von seiner zweiten
frau und einem missratenen drehbuch an
dem er jahrelang geschrieben hat stürzte
völlig unerwartet in die größte krise
seines lebens psychiatrische
universitätsklinik zürich
rolf ließ sie weiß sich 1998 ins
burgholz die 1
diagnose schwere depression innerhalb
weniger minuten habe es in seinem kopf
klick gemacht
eine unbeschreibliche panik ergreift ihn
was mache ich jetzt aber nicht die stadt
st
wir haben eine schätzte finde kann
machen was eigentlich wichtig dass ich
eben wie von der sozialhilfe abhängig
werden und dass ich verlange und dass
ich als einfach nur machen schaffen
reif zwei depressionsforscher
die depression reist den regisseur immer
mehr in die tiefe
er realisiert wenn er nicht in der
psychiatrischen klinik bleibt wird etwas
passieren
es hat dass unser name gespräch geht
oder dann ist die frage nach suizid
fantasien oder und das kann ich mich
dann nicht getraut sage aber ich muss
irgendwann im dark ist irgendwann der
sich überzeichnet ich halte das nicht
mehr nur das ist sie anders als man
denkt ja jeden tag irgendwann spritze
während ich mich da verabschieden will
das ist nützen muss halt das opfer kommt
[Musik]
man muss sich das vorstellen dass
gedanken ins rotieren und zwar nur in
eine negative spirale nötig gemacht
mittags essen gestorben
[Musik]
und schlimm steh ich bin schön versuchen
ein rad schlägt geht es hat dann die
erklärung seite beispiel die muss
irgendwo hier auf der insel oder macht
das oder nimmt das aber im johannes gut
und alles erzeugt oder minder und israel
hat micha kunzi mehr oder
und da bin ich absolut nicht in der lage
sind ich kann vor dem hallen wählen
nach drei monaten klinikaufenthalt
geschieht eine art wunder schließlich
spürt das erste mal wieder seine gefühle
die krankheit geht wie sie gekommen ist
kürzlich sagte eigentlichen schicksal
bis zum letzten atemzug dankbar dass ich
das überlebt
oder dass jene klappt es freut und ich
habe wieder lachen wieder eine chance
für alle denen das ist der punkt oder
einen film machen dass ich einfach 600
langen abschnitt der amputation es aber
eine vorstellung besuchen
[Musik]
wieder arbeiten wieder lachen wieder
velo fahren
einmal die woche macht er 80 jährige
eine zweistündige wedelt rolf ließ hatte
nie wieder eine depression
[Musik]
jetzt bin fahre ich hoffe da kann man
nicht das muss ist noch mal machen
ja ich bin einfach ich bin begeistert
über den schönen tag
man hat so gedanken mal es fließt alles
oder blut fliesst gedanken fließen die
saft füßen
[Musik]
jeden donnerstagabend dem winter trifft
sich rolf ließ sie im hotel eden au lac
in zürich mit seiner jazzband zum
feierabend konzert seit über zehn jahren
dies sei seine beste krippe prophylaxe
[Musik]
der schlagzeuger rolf ließ sie ist
autodidakt neben dem film ist es seine
zweite leidenschaft
[Musik]
musik ist lapp helix ihrer inspiration
musik ist einfach gut
[Musik]
ihre weiblichen fans sie was hat
eigentlich die musik
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sie sind allein stehen sie ganz alte
mitre partnerin verbraucht weil eine
intime frage ich fühle mich sehr wohl
und ich kann einige lang langjährige
beziehung mit tolle frauen die an ideen
so toll sie sind aber ich habe ihn teil
dazu beitragen die drei dass es
funktioniert hat und manche schätzen
funktioniert da habe ich alle piste zur
betreibt ich glaube man wird immer damit
immer wieder damit konfrontiert dass man
nur der preis zahle für office hit muss
ich sagen könnte ich mir jetzt vorstelle
mit partner wie sage ich der grieche
wohl aber dass ich jetzt einfach vorbei
ich bin aber nicht unglücklich dass
werke eine partnerschaft sich verliere
wunderbar das größte verlierer ist
wirklich wunderbar aber es hat auch die
sitte gefährliche und sich an auf um im
leben immer schritt für schritt erklärt
wie man mit dem computer
aber ich weiß immer noch das rezept für
ihre ewig tour in die beziehung
ich glaube also für mich gibt es das
sowieso nicht was heißt das wenn man
über 80 und weiß man hat noch viel zeit
verwandt
ja ich kann jetzt härtere und
und klagen und und mich innerlich
zerfressen
das ist eine möglichkeit an stiegen die
ganz garantiert ganz schnell
oder aber man nimmt so ist ich mache dem
niveaus wie mich sterben und sind eines
tages nehme da nur sage ich mir bist
dann wo dix einfach so gut wie möglich
erhalten
wirklich glücklich bin ich dann meine
ich wenn es mir klingt engines machen wo
die tanklager im kino sitzen und
publikum spüren und spüre dass man
richtig geschafft hat dass man richtig
dank hat der schon bis großartig
das hauptmotiv würde ich sagen zum
traben liebe
[Musik]